good morning
I will call the fiscal committee meeting
to order for April 21st 2023 and first
we'll recognize the legislative budget
assistant
Michael Kane for an explanation of a
proposal
on changing some of our rules
sure thank you good morning Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Michael Kane the legislative
budget assistant for the State of New
Hampshire item number one on your agenda
is a request to amend the fiscal
communities rules and procedures and
this is what directs our office to what
we can and cannot include on your agenda
so the request before you there are two
options and the request is basically for
the months of May and June to allow
items that utilize funding from the
American Rescue plan or the bipartisan
infrastructure law or any other
previously enacted Federal relief bills
to be authorized through June 30th 2025.
that statement is basically saying if I
receive an item in Das receives an item
that goes beyond June 30th 2023 has to
be related to these buckets of money and
then we would allow it on the agenda
which then the committee would take a
vote at that time to either approve or
so does everyone understand normally
we're only dealing with the present
biennium however every member of this
committee is going to be a vote for or
against the budget for the next biennium
so it isn't isn't as if we have no
control going forward of those funds
because we'll all be in some manner
voting for them so although this is an
exception to what we do I think that in
my mind it's still something we are in
some control of it does save a lot of
paperwork and perhaps layoffs that might
otherwise occur should we not approve
one of these options for changing in our
rules
Senator Bradley moves the moves that we
adopt
just to pick one again option two
have you looked at the two options
is it for option two you're moving
senator
all right
and Senator Rosen while seconds that we
adopt option two
is there any further discussion
all in favor say aye
oppose no
that is adopted thank you
all right moving on to the rest of our
business
under tab two acceptance of the minutes
from the previous meeting of March 24th
Senator gray moves to adopt
Senator Bradley seconds that we adopt
the minutes any additions or Corrections
seeing none
further discussion all in favor adopting
their minutes as written say aye
aye opposed no
the minutes are adopted we don't have
any old business to deal with
we have a consent calendar
that goes through tabs four five six
seven eight and nine there were 24 items
I'll tell you the items that I've been
asked to remove and if you've if you
have something you've asked to remove
that I miss please tell me so
under tab six I'm removing 23 110
23 11.
under tab seven I'm removing
and under tab eight twenty three one one
two
under tab nine I'm removing tab I'm
removing item twenty three one two four
are there any other items that any
Senator Rosenwald thank you under tab 9
has the item
one two three been withdrawn it has been
withdrawn right thank you we have we
have them a note to that so that that's
not thank you not on our agenda at the
present time
seeing none I'll entertain a motion to
adopt the rest of the consent calendar
with the exception of the aforementioned
bills so move second Senator gray moves
Senator Bradley seconds that we adopt
the rest the consent calendar any
further discussion seeing none you're
ready for the question all in favor say
aye aye opposed no
the rest of the consent calendar is
is 23110 Department of Business and
economic affairs
do we have someone here to answer
questions
representative erf has a question on the
and this is also related to 23 122 so it
might be
well to discuss them at the same time
so instead of asking this question twice
so what does Equity have to do with
broadband and why is that a
consideration in
accepting these federal funds so under
the so what we've been dealing with to
this point has been uh funding that's
provided to the state through arpa and
the capital projects fund those were the
the items that we had before you last
summer and then again last fall
um these funds are now shifting us over
to the bipartisan infrastructure lot or
bil or iija or whichever acronym you
choose
um this is a different part of resources
included in that law is a require is a a
funding source to assist
States in this matter of digital Equity
so in most cases in our in our industry
what we're going to be looking at is the
fact that we're going to be hooking up a
lot of rural communities both with the
previous funds and with the funds that
we have yet to uh to receive and as part
of that there is an initiative within
the federal federal law that would allow
for assistance for people who are not
used to dealing with digital uh
interactions so an example would be for
elderly populations that would be using
Telehealth or getting access using a
laptop or a computer it would be funds
that would be allowed used through the
state to help those individuals access
the digital component of the Broadband
hookups
so I'm going to talk about these
together now just so I understand what's
going on this is for half a million the
other one's roughly the other one's for
2 million maybe you just describe the
difference between the two but more
importantly the question I have for
based on what you just said was
I'll be talking about some of the
funding maybe that two million dollars
being to provide support to the
individuals who need this help or we're
making decisions about who gets the
Broadband access based on some sort of
equity no no nothing to do with the
former this is exclusively about helping
people access the internet using the fun
the hookups and the funds that we'll be
using to connect those those locations
so it's it's not
um deciding who gets the Broadband it's
just it's assisting people once they
have it how they use it right so that's
the primary purpose of the digital
Equity Fund the other item under uh 122
that is a requirement to get
um access to the next tranche of funding
under the bil for continued activity in
driving more Broadband infrastructure in
the state so there's a significant
amount of money that would come as a
result of us completing that study the
two million dollar item yeah we it we
don't know what the final number will be
but we do expect that it would be in
excess of 100 million dollars additional
so if I'm not mistaken and I don't have
it right in front of me I believe that
one also makes reference to broadband
equity so both of them I refer in many
places to the whole digital Equity
component under the federal law that the
thing to bear in mind is that these two
items will result in access to two
different pots of money but they are
both under that Federal bil uh sort of
moniker
so does that mean the word Equity is
just that's in the title the federal law
or whatever that's not that's nothing to
do with what the second pot of money is
about what is the second pot of money
about the two million dollars what is
that actually so the the bead funding
under the section uh
all right if I had a chart it would be a
lot more helpful so we have the the
bipartisan infrastructure law the
infrastructure legislation within that
is a uh is the Broadband I mean excuse
me the bead program within bead program
there is a digital Equity component and
then there is the infrastructure
expansion component we're talking about
both of them here uh the digital Equity
we're requesting uh 525 000 to pay a
contractor to to to write the plan that
will then be submitted to the federal
government which should unlock funding
for digital Equity activities that I
described earlier uh the other uh the
other pot of money the two million
dollars would be for a contractor to
um to design a plan that we would then
again submit to the federal government
and upon their approval would unlock
another pot of money that would be the
100 million dollar item that I refer to
here and that's for the infrastructure
Investments them so elves
I hope that makes some sense so no that
does make sense but now let's stick to
the two million dollar piece the plan
being because the title of it is for
Broadband Equity access yeah so I'm just
wondering now does that plan that you're
developing need to be related to equity
in some in some form as far as how the
Broadband access is going to be provided
as opposed to an approach that gets the
biggest bang for the buck
because you're now you're talking about
if I understand what you just said now
you're talking about the transom money
to actually install Broadband I
understand your question our
understanding right now and uh is that
the equity component is referring to
people having uh access to the internet
not access to the Broadband itself we
will continue on the track that we are
on currently which is expanding access
to unserved and underserved areas of the
state with these resources
another Forum I went to
it here they're going down a road and if
someone has a thousand foot long
driveway to get to their house they
exclude them
because they won't want to spend the
extra money to to send that much wire
might even require another poll so
Equity means you don't skip them you're
going to give them
access as well even though they might
have their their residence further from
the road that you're running the wire
down so it that's that's what the equity
is you got to cover everybody on the
road not just the ones that are close by
that's my understanding yes that that
would be a correct interpretation we are
making sure that people get that access
we're currently in that instance that
you describe uh they would basically be
charged for that thousand feet of their
driveway whereas that would not be the
case with these resources
representative leishman for a question
thank you Mr chairman so several months
ago we were approved dozens and dozens
of millions of dollars for Broadband
expense expansion we had a number of
people sitting here encouraging us to
vote that way has anything happened
there as far as if you put contracts out
as expansion started yes in both cases
so uh you'll remember there were two uh
the first one a Broadband connect
program we'll call it round one was
awarded to the New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative they have already begun work
they have I think they're in 50
different communities they're doing work
right now they're ramping up this spring
to be able to put they tell me 20 miles
a week of fiber uh out in the
communities The second contract was
awarded to Consolidated Communications
they are already beginning their work in
planning for this Summer's construction
season both of them are under pretty
strict time restrictions because these
are so they're moving quickly
right now what we're seeing what we're
expecting from both of these contracts
is to be able to connect 50
000 new locations in New Hampshire that
are either unserved or underserved and
chairman Senator Rosenwald for a
question thank you Mr chairman so
is this going to be one contractor who
gets
two contracts I'm trying to figure out
when is like you get the Broadband so
then you could watch TV or maybe have
a digital phone and internet and the
other one is teaching people to use the
internet well not so much to use the
internet but to
with the high-speed internet in
communities that don't have that
capability right now
um you have people that have not had the
experience necessarily of using their
computer to talk with their doctor or to
manage their finances or to do those
sorts of functions the federal law
included resources to help states meet
that
meet the requirements of those
individuals so that's what the that one
the item 110 is for that is the higher
we'll put out an RFP for a consultant to
uh to complete that plan on our behalf
which would then be submitted to the
federal government if it's accepted then
we unlock some resource for that
particular purpose it's the same process
um for the second item 122. it's for a
third party contractor to write a plan
which then you know to meet the federal
requirements we would submit that to the
federal government and then that unlocks
an additional resource for the
further questions remember we are
discussing both items 23 111 and 23 one
two two
I'm sorry 23 110 and 23 122.
any further discussion I'll entertain a
motion to adopt uh 110 23 110. I'll move
both items if you want
all right that'll be fine you uh
representative Earth moves both
representative 23 110 and 23122
second by uh Senator Bradley further
discussion seeing Nani ready for the
question to accept these two items all
in favor say aye opposed no those items
are adopted excuse me we're moving to
23-11
and we also have questions on that
Department of Health and Human Services
good morning Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services good morning
Trisha Tilley director of Public Health
good morning
um representative leishman had questions
on item number 23-111
thank you Mr chairman uh thanks for
taking my question on your page five it
lists the state agencies that are
receiving grants or Estates or Indian
tribes Etc and I was just curious
looking at the comparison between Maine
and Vermont Maine and Vermont are
receiving a lot more money than we are
is that because of Eligibility that more
people in Maine are eligible versus New
Hampshire I'm assuming that but I just
wanted to make sure that is correct
that mean more children or more low
income uh proportion of we were probably
certainly a greater proportion of low
income
thank you
Senator Rosamond thank you are we
reaching every eligible person in New
Hampshire and we just have fewer
eligible or are there things we could be
doing sure so um we are certainly not
reaching every eligible person in New
Hampshire let me rephrase that everyone
who is eligible for WIC does not
participate is probably the safest way
to say that we have been doing extensive
Outreach efforts
um we believe we've actually seen an
uptick after years of declining
enrollment we are now seeing an uptick
again we think that's in part due to the
pandemic it may also be in part right
now as SNAP benefits decrease people are
coming back to using WIC as well because
WIC is you know snap is a cash benefit
WIC is a food package so it's a little
bit more complicated or at least
restrictive than cash benefits
thank you
for the questions from the committee
move the item
representative Alicia leishman moves the
item Senator Bradley seconds it further
discussion seeing none you're ready for
the question all in favor say aye oppose
no we've adopted item 2311.
this is the Department of administrative
Services welcome
good morning I'm Sheri Rockburn I'm the
assistant commissioner for the
and
this was a someone had a question on the
again I believe it was because of the
fact that there seemed to be a big
difference even though the last item
had a big difference in uh
qualification among the New England
states this this was a different kind of
alignment
and we wondered why why one one program
is affected by the poverty in this one
so I can
attachment B yeah New Hampshire this
time has about the same amount of money
as Rhode Island
and about half as much less than half as
much as Maine
and
obviously a lot more than Vermont
so
we're wondering about the
the different criteria that they vary
from state to state we saw in the last
one that the other states seem to have
more poverty
now that's not the case so what is this
based on yeah
um the director was unavailable to be
here this morning so the questions that
I thought were coming through the LBA
was about the the program itself and the
Commodities so I brought that
information with me
so I can let me find out a little bit
more about that mechanics of the program
in terms of why our dollars would have
changed senator
Senator D'Alessandro uh thank you yeah I
did have a question about the
Commodities the commodity distribution
program and uh what was happening with
regard to that I've been involved with
that for a long period of time
so I can speak to that in terms of the
program itself on the formula I can try
to get that answered before the end of
the meeting to get back to you on that
in terms of the program itself we
receive funding through the federal
government for assistance for food
service we contract with one
organization it's the community action
program of Belknap and Merrimack
and the funding that we receive is both
for administrative costs to run the
program and then also sort of the value
of the food
that organization the warehouse is
located in industrial on Industrial
Drive up in the in the Heights sort of
near 106 route 106. the food gets
delivered there from the U.S department
of Agriculture and then it gets
distributed to local organizations
throughout New Hampshire food banks
pantries Etc homeless shelters
in fiscal 22 last year we received about
4.3 million in food value
this grant or the item in front of you
is to accept additional money for the
administrative cost of the program and I
do have a list I sent it through the LBA
but can provide it to all of you who
haven't seen it is the types of
Commodities which really range from
almonds up through peanut butter through
chicken so it really is you know both
perishable and non-perishable Goods okay
thank you thank you Miss Jim
the other puzzling thing was why did
administrative Services get involved
I don't know if I I don't know the
answer of or if anyone at HHS knows that
um it goes through our department I
don't know the the back story on that
it's been running through our department
um since the Inception of the program so
I'd have to do a little digging of why
for the discussion from the committee
I'll entertain a motion to adopt movie
3137.
motion by Senator D'Alessandro second by
Senator Bradley to adopt the item
further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say aye aye
opposed no the item is adopted
next item number
I have several of that's okay that's
fine
um the first one that I think is easy
turned it off and
opening it on so good morning I'm Katya
Fox I'm the director of the division for
Behavioral Health and the centers that
are so there are three centers as you
indicated Manchester received a planning
Grant which has actually concluded and
then the other two in that have current
grants are Nashua and West's Central
sorry I have to write too many things
down here once
okay so the next question is it makes
reference to developing new Medicaid
Payment Systems can you tell me what
that means yes so as part of this
process
um there are certain requirements about
um how the clinics are set up so they
have criteria and I think some of that
is included in this request
um there is also a requirement that we
look at how we reimburse the um the
centers in this model so that is why
some of the funding is going to go for
our actuary to be able to help us with
that but it's on the premise of a
prospective payment which is the way
that we currently fund our federally
qualified Health Centers and our
hospitals
and Henry Whitman is here if if there
are more Medicaid funding questions
maybe let's go to him then
um so it also talks about improved
models and infrastructure for data and
metrics tracking and quality oversight
so I have two questions related to this
what metrics are being tracked and how
will we and the public be able to see
the results of that tracking I.E well so
we will know that you're being
successful that the program is
successful or less successful
so again thank you for that question
this is going to really provide us the
outcome data that we've all been
searching for we often have that process
data and we count how many people served
and
um and ages and demographics and things
but this will allow us to look at
outcome data to see how successful the
the clinics are in their work with
individuals
and the second part of that was and how
will we the legislature and the public
also be able to understand how
successful they were absolutely we have
reporting requirements but beyond that
it's really important for us to be
um sharing that information so that
you'll have it we all have it and we've
done a lot of work within the department
to create dashboards and to create
accessible data for transparency and for
every the public to see how we're doing
so that will be part of this process as
well
great I hope when we do the budget in
the next cycle at the very least we
would see that kind of feedback
absolutely we all need it thank you
Senator Rosenwald for a question yeah
um the prospective payment system that's
a higher reimbursement
rate isn't it it's sort of a
I don't know I think the community
health centers
they get a higher level of payment
do you do you know what the differential
is in
amounts that
maybe would
increase funding to these Community
Mental Health Centers if we went to the
perfect perspective payment system yeah
I think there are a lot of discussions
and a lot of theories of what that would
be and what that would look like and how
much more it would be I do not have that
information because that's the purpose
of the planning Grant is to go through
that process what we want to make sure
is that the providers are paid for the
services that they're delivering and
that it's high quality care and there's
access for individuals so whether that
is going to be more we know we have the
budget that was passed by the house and
into the Senate that has significant
Medicaid rate increases which goes a
long way toward helping our providers in
and if Henry wants to stand up behind me
he's welcome to but
um he has more experience in in this
payment methodology than I do
um because of the providers we're
good morning for the record Henry
Littman the state's Medicaid director
I think we do have to do the Actuarial
work but the basic gist of the model
that's being evaluated is to provide a
more stable funding to community health
centers so that they can make the
Investments and Staffing and what have
you we currently work under
um sort of a two-level system right now
one where
um there are the FIFA Service rates plus
under the Managed Care Program the cmhcs
participate in decapitation contract so
it's hard to know whether someone's
going to be
better off or worse off with respect to
their finances until we do a little bit
more analytical work here but generally
I think the the funding sources intended
to provide a little more certainty in
terms of streams of funding so that I
think they can invest in the services to
and certainly it would be part of a a
budget that you would get to vote on in
representative erf move the item if
representative excuse me representative
erf moves 23-138 Senator dalessandro
seconds further discussion seeing none
are you ready for the question all in
favor say aye
aye opposed no that item is adopted
the next one I had removed was 23 128
good morning good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
Josh Elliott director of the division of
policy and programs with New Hampshire
Doe
Senator representative Earth did you
have a question
yes
um so I'm only vaguely from the LIHEAP
and I know what it is and that's all
about and it's been going on for quite
some time
so my question is not related to the
funding for that that's obviously great
as far as I'm concerned but what is your
current Staffing for running this
program and why do you need more staff
to run a program that's been going for
quite some time as I understand it sure
thank you very much for the question so
our current Staffing and we have two
staff members who currently uh 100 of
their time is devoted to this program we
are requesting a second staff excuse me
a third uh staffer in order to help
improve efficiencies in the program
again you're seeing uh you know over 80
million dollars just being handled by
two folks
um you have the increasing complexity
with Federal requirements on this
program
um we've had additional duties assigned
based on the federal grants including
set up a water assistance program as
part of LIHEAP so we're seeing great uh
increasing complexity with complying
with Federal requirements for this
program that necessitates uh adding a
third staffer who again will be able to
improve efficiencies current staff is
pre-stretched then as it is so it'll
so if I'm not mistaken this is a
temporary full-time position does that
imply that it's this is only temporarily
needed or or what's going to happen
at some point
um we will thank you for the question um
so we will evaluate over the course of
the the next biennium obviously there'll
be an item to to re-up this um once the
new biennium starts
um we'll take a look at this once we
come in for the now the current budget
but the the I should say not the current
budget under consideration but the
subsequent budget after that as to
whether or not either Federal
Regulations have changed there's some
other changes with the program
um and either will um
ah we'll see what we need in terms of
Staffing at that point
thank you
I see you have uh several write-ups on
this program in this in this
single audit Federal audit so is this
person going to possibly help with some
of those
write-ups that have been brought up some
of them the second a third time
I yes thank you for the question um yes
having those extra staff will make sure
that you know we're following everything
to the T we're making sure we're
communicating with our business offices
make sure that we're following all
further discussion from committee
members
Senator Bradley move so you adopt the
item Senator Rosenwald seconds is there
any further discussion seeing none all
in favor say aye aye opposed no the item
item one one two twenty three one twelve
is from the Department of Health and
representative irf did you have a
question
thank you Mr chair
yeah so why are we specifically
concerned with and this is a quote from
the
document the mission of ojjdp is to
reduce the number of minority youth
disproportionately serviced in the
that's been a core mission of ojjdp for
as far as I know decades and the reason
why it's been a core mission is that
nationally there has been great
disproportionality in terms of minority
youth in the juvenile justice system and
in the adult correctional system
so one of the core focuses of ojjdp in a
requirement of the Federal grant is that
states do work to look at the
disproportionality within their systems
and try to do work to help find ways to
reduce the disproportionality within
their systems
thank you
so I'm assuming we're talking about
cisie but other things but primarily
um
and well we've always had a lot of
recent discussions about
who should be in there and that sort of
thing
and I've had the impression that the
decisions regarding who should be in
there have nothing to do with race or
ethnicity or anything of that nature so
I'm wondering why
you know we need to look at this
so the juvenile justice system is a lot
bigger than just the facility but I do
have data that shows here and it's
consistent nationally that the minority
youth are disproportionately part of the
Juvenile Justice System whether that's
at the arrest decision point at the
decision point to file petitions at the
decision point to put a young person on
probation at the decision point to put a
young person in placement or at the
decision point to have a young person be
detained or committed
um
not because explicitly race is a factor
in those decisions but those are the
outcomes that we see in the data and
that's the reason why for again going
back I think 20 plus years this has been
something that ojjdp has required states
to consider and try to find ways to
mitigate
so
isn't it possible that it's because they
commit more offenses that put them into
that situation I think there's a lot of
things that are possible but I think
there are probably many contributing
factors to why we see those outcomes and
I think they're probably
um you know underlying factors that
cause those outcomes as well in terms of
the types of supports and services that
are provided to different communities is
related to you know historical you know
inequities in the way that folks have
been treated over time I think there's
lots of things that result in this
impact but nevertheless the impact is
so that's the case will there be
something you produce that we all get a
hold of to understand if in fact that is
the case that it's because of race that
that people are being inappropriately
put into the system I want to be very
careful I'm not saying that they're
being put in because of race in terms of
it being an intentional decision that
people are doing to put you know to to
make these choices what I'm saying is
that the outcome in the data which I
could produce and have a whole meeting
on it if we want shows that this is true
in both the child protection and the
Juvenile Justice systems
so I'm not questioning the data I'm
questioning your I'm asking is what's
coming out of this an explanation of why
we're seeing the data and I'm quite
honestly I'm less concerned with
historically 20 years ago and we're
concerned with currently because it
seems to me there's an implication here
that there's something other than
the the people that are there are
committed or or found
guilty of offenses
based on something besides the fact that
they did something wrong
yeah and again right understanding the
decision making that individuals make at
all these different points at the point
of first contact with with law
enforcement at the point of arrest at
the point of whether or not to file a
petition at the point of whether or not
to to find that petition true and to
have a young person go on probation or
be placed or go to sysc all of those
decision points there's lots and lots of
factors that go in there I don't have
the ability to to pick apart every
decision in every case and tell you why
those decisions make why those decisions
are made what I can tell you is that the
outcomes are what the outcomes are and
the goal of this is to look at trying to
find ways to mitigate that now we are
actively trying to find ways to mitigate
mitigate that right now the Juvenile
Justice Assessment program that we spend
a lot of time talking about on the house
side in particular which really has the
goal of identifying youth needs early
and making sure that youth are connected
with resources early before they get
pulled deeper into the Juvenile Justice
System part of the goal of that is to
try to help impact this because we also
know that Minority youth are less likely
to have access to some of those types of
Supportive Services in the first
instance so you would be able to
hopefully divert some of those folks to
get the Supportive Services they need
and prevent them from ending up deeper
into the Juvenile Justice System
let me be more direct will you be
providing us a report on what you find
whether it's whatever the factors are
will you be telling us what these
factors are so we understand what in
fact is going into these all these
decision points you're talking about
that you say right now you're not aware
of what the what they could be it's a
much more complex if I knew how to
answer that question as to why we see
disproportionate racial outcomes across
so many systems in this country
um I I wish that I could answer that
question I I do not have the depth of
knowledge to answer that question what I
can tell you is that there is there's a
committee that just met yesterday with
assistant commissioner Eddie Edwards at
safety with Partners from across the
state that look specifically at this
information and review the data about
what we're seeing and try to figure out
what are ways that we can try to better
impact this outcome
but as a result of that can't you report
on it what's your what you found I mean
it seems to me that if there's a problem
and you're correcting something you must
be able to talk about what you corrected
in other words you keep saying it's so
difficult I get all that but I'm not
what I'm not getting is why we can't
learn what these issues are yeah I have
as I said I've I've put together a
pretty comprehensive deck of data on
exactly this point I'd be happy to come
in and talk through both the data and
both the things that we that we think
are impacting that I think I'm probably
not the only person who could have that
conversation I think there's a lot of
people who have done work in this space
in this state that are probably even
more qualified than me to be able to go
into that including many of the folks
that sit on this committee that met
some of us think the causes are more
tied with poverty neighborhood and
fatherless homes rather than race and
rather than trying to attribute to that
single Factor witness all these other
ones seem to be in play that we think
that should come
in that study
further discussion from committee
members
Senator gray moves
Senator Bradley seconds to adopt the
item further discussion
seeing none
all in favor say aye aye opposed no no
wish to be recorded I recorded myself
all right
moving on to tab nine
we have an item
Department of Health and Human Services
again
morning Karen Hebert for the division of
economic stability for DHHS
thank you
representative err for a question
tired of me on
um I think this is the last one I'm
gonna
get into I'm just curious as to this is
all about mortgage lease payments
deferred maintenance and so on in terms
of what the monies are covering
and I'm just an expansion expanding
outdoor spaces and so on
but the title of this or the lead in if
you will the the headline is it's to
strengthen Workforce which I assume
means
be able to bring more people in to do
the job can you just speak to how the
one helps the other
sure it's a great question thank you so
this is entirely about strengthening the
workforce and the intent behind this
basically is with the reduction in
operating costs such as mortgages and
the other examples in this
would free up funding in order to pay
either higher wages or better benefits
for the workforce for the purposes of
strengthening the retention and
recruitment efforts that are so needed
in child care providers
follow-up
so when you distribute the funds is
there going to be some tie-in or
expectation that that the result of the
savings up to the child care centers
will be that that money gets reinvested
in Staffing as opposed to just
reinvested in themselves yes correct so
we will we're putting the details
together now but we really want to
develop a formula that is fair and
Equitable but providers will need to
demonstrate or provide that verification
that they did reinvest the funding into
their Workforce
Senator Rosenwald thank you
some of this
um infrastructure building seems like
well take some time
wouldn't it be faster to just
invest
these resources
into
the workforce either through
I don't know enrollment based payment or
stipends or something that would get
the money to these centers to the
workforce more quickly why are you
approaching it
like it's not the first result it's the
second result of the money following up
on
representative her question it just
seems like it's going to take longer and
it's more indirect
sure thank you another excellent
question so there are this is a
multi-faceted issue which really needs a
multiple multiple solutions that are
both short-term and sustainable for the
long term
so the department put together the child
care strengthening plan last year as a
result of Senate Bill 446. there are
many initiatives that were mentioned in
that strengthening plan this is just one
of them
and this is the one that gopher had
provided the award for
so in addition to that we do have a
number of initiatives that we're
implementing now that may address
exactly what you're referring to that
are more immediate and that is through
the arpa discretionary funding so the
state is currently putting together a
number of procurements to address a
number of the other initiatives
including a recruitment and retention
project that would essentially provide a
pilot program with effective strategies
for attracting retaining and increasing
the Recruitment and strengthening the
thank you but part of the problem that
we hear is the capacity issue
so
why
does creating playgrounds
increase capacity for the number of
children
that can be cared for in these
facilities I'm just not singing that
connection sure great thank you so the
the idea behind something like a
playground so if there is a provider
that essentially doesn't really have
that kind of facility but they have
plans that they would like to be able to
provide you know something like a
playground that needs to be appropriate
it needs to be age appropriate and of
quality
so if they have plans that they're
implementing that and that is where they
are investing but at the same time
having this problem with Recruitment and
Retention so that they can't
they're not able to bring in the right
number of Staff or keep the right number
of staff that would match their capacity
so there are a number of programs that
are operating under capacity because
they don't have the workforce to to take
on more children that they have slots
for
so by investing in something like you're
covering that kind of an operating cost
that would significantly improve a
provider's facility
that would free up those funding so that
they can provide they can allow for
greater wages or better benefits that
would attract more people in to that
particular industry with that there are
a number of other initiatives going on
at the same time to really look at the
different pipelines of where where can
we really recruit people from number of
partners that we want to start to invest
in including the business Community
where we can really look at ways of
partnering with businesses so that we do
meet the needs of those businesses and
employees that would be working in
did the depart wide in the department
ask for money to do those things rather
than this longer term and more indirect
approach our request for uh in the child
care strengthening plan that was
submitted to gopher also provided to the
legislature we asked for a number of
of of items
um including
funding for Recruitment and Retention
one of the items included funding to
help stabilize further the child care
providers so that it would attribute to
Recruitment and Retention this is the
item thus far that has been awarded
for the questions on the item
I'm going to turn a motion to adopt
move to adopt
Senator gray moves to adopt the item
Senator Bradley seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye
opposed no
how many knows
two
moving on to tab 11.
item 23 114. did I skip one thank you
all right this is Health and Human
Services
Senator Rosenwald thank you
um
scheduled to get
just
seems like a sinkhole
and
it just is such a giant amount of money
in the budget every year and then
items like this why
so
um as as we'll be discussing on uh
Monday or Tuesday I believe Medicaid is
coming to Senate Finance next week
um we the the maintenance costs for the
mmis system are are significant uh
approximately 80 million dollars or so
over the biennium
um this the the the
transfer that that we're requesting here
is to fund a recent amendment in Henry I
don't know if you want to speak to the
details there sure one of the major
pieces of this is a function of
um when providers query the system and
get a response on people's eligibility
as you know our enrollment and Medicaid
went from 178 000 to to 250 almost 252
000 at its peak and now with the unwind
um there's a lot more need for providers
to be able to to be able to reach out
and check people's eligibility
um and we in terms of what was in the
original amendment to to fund that type
of service and interaction with the
system
um
we need more more opportunities to do
that otherwise providers will try to
query and they won't be able to get it
the MMA
system has been problematic for many
many years
and we
we talk about this at fiscal we talk
about it during the budget cycle we talk
about Appropriations we talk about the
match we talk about what's being done
isn't there any way where there could be
some uniformity across the country with
regard to this system because everybody
has to make these reports
is it is it isn't that an opportunity to
get something that makes that makes
sense
um
other than that
these kinds of Appropriations even
though they're significant matches and
I'm not I I understand that I mean it
used to be a 90-10 and now I don't know
what the match is now but but indeed
every year we look we look at this and
you give us good rationale I understand
that but there's got to be a more
uniform system in place
that everyone that must report is able
to take advantage of
I just find this to be incomprehensible
I was in the software business for for a
while and we were able to do things like
that but
this is this occurrence goes on and on
and on
so I guess I'd like to answer in two
parts
um I guess the first part is when you've
seen one Medicaid Program you've seen
one Medicaid Program in many respects
unlike software you can take off the
shelf
um that's not the case because as each
state has little idiosyncrasies with
respect to how they want the eligibility
to work and other things the reality is
that it's you can't buy in many
instances uh information off the
software off the shelf
I guess I would also say that I think of
commissioner goulet's here that the
operation of the system today has vastly
improved in the last few years and the
second thing is that in which we'll be
talking to you at the Senate Finance
about is whereas you know I think the
original system was installed
um and
acquired when we were in a
fee-for-service system so after we made
and this is long before my time after we
made that investment we converted to a
managed care approach which required a
lot of rework to to get the system to to
line up with that but that's just an
example of you know when you buy it for
one function and then put it to use in
another function it does require a lot
of changes but in terms of how the
system is functioning
um it is at I think of commissioner
glaze behind me I think he would shake
his head yes and I've heard him say it
at uh at governor and Council because
the same kind of concerns that you raise
come up at governor and Council as well
um
but the other thing that I think from a
forward-looking standpoint is the
strategy of modularity meaning that
rather than relying on one vendor to
provide everything
um and you're when you go out to bid
you're making a massive commitment to
one vendor the the strategy going
forward is to to
um
put it in pieces so that you can create
more Market competition for the
components that you're you're buying and
that's that's the direction that we're
going in in uh and that's honestly in
terms of what CMS will support because
they've seen these massive systems that
are singular vendored have not been
inexpensive to run that they're trying
to create more competition by creating
different modules that get pulled
together
okay thank you
Senator Rosemont thank you separately
we're um
by approving this item losing 10 million
dollars of federal funds that's a
difference sure
um but uh well that's related yeah it's
not really a time of my ass but it's
this item
what
what programs
or Services might be affected by the
loss of
sure there's 10 million dollars so
there's a couple of transfers within the
Medicaid accounts that you'll see um
we're moving funds to chip uh based on
higher enrollments and the need there
we're moving it out of the main Medicaid
accounts of the the 7948
um we have additional dollars as a
result of the 6.2 F map that just phased
out April 1. now we're at five percent
for the time being the
um the state face down payments that you
see there those were those were under
budgeted in the current biennium we do
have a prioritized need request that has
gone unfunded today to 15 million
dollars for the current biennium we
don't receive any match on that payment
it's 100 General funds and so by moving
that out of the 7948 we're reducing the
50 50 match and that's the 10 million
dollars of federal funds that you see in
the reduction there thank you you're
welcome
thank you Mr chair
so that's several I'll give you what
should be an easy one first but I'm
interested if you can answer it
this makes reference to account number
5191 special Medical Services
I could not find 5191 in any of the
documents that I have
um 5191 is within the Bureau of
Developmental Services it's the special
Medicaid or medical services it is
contained within the
so I can't look it up right now because
I don't have what you'd have but I'll
tell you why I did look it up I didn't
see it I have the an actual spreadsheet
for the h
the HP hb1 is it past the house it's not
in there and I also have a document
produced by LBA which is on their
website which compares
the governor's request to
what we did in the house and I couldn't
search for it in there either and I
could search for anything else so if if
you if you look at the current House
Bill one
um for the it is on page 618 of the
current operating budget okay
okay page six eighteen page six eighteen
correct
thank you
all right I guess that was the easy one
good
so now get to the ones I really care
about
so 7948 which is Medicaid services and
you talked about a lot of money coming
out of that one correct
okay 13 million dollars of if I'm not
mistaken which says that there was 13
million dollars in there that would have
lapsed
or the will lapse and I'm just curious
as to oh and and I might add that 30
million relapse in that account this
year
you requested and we granted if I'm not
reading this incorrectly for fy2425 an
increase of 25 million dollars in year
one and 35 million dollars a year to
so we're potentially lapsing 13 million
from a much smaller budget and we're yet
we're still we're still asked to
increase the budget over the coming
years so really two two questions why
was the 13 million I brought up during
the budget cycle and why was so much
asked for in the next biennium sure so
when when we're looking at the Medicaid
Program we're looking across all of the
accounts and the projections that we're
seeing the state phase down has been a
known shortfall that we've had uh since
since July 1 of of the prior State
fiscal year so when we look at those
calculations we make that assumption
with what we're going to be carrying
forward or what we'll have available to
so 7948 is the state phase down account
no it is not the state phase down
account but when we look at the the
entirety of the Medicaid Program chip
standard Medicaid uh State face down
we're we're looking at those numbers in
totality to figure out what are we going
to be needing
um are we going to be sure are we going
to be lapsing funds
well that's great but we're talking
about one particular count 7948
which apparently would have lapsed will
lapse 13 million if we don't approve
this
number one and number two in the next
biennium it's budgeted at 60 million
dollars more than this biennium so can
you just speak to both of those how can
you square both of those circles sure
with respect to the 2223 budget the
Assumption was that the federal Public
Health Emergency in the beginning of the
unwind would start in October of uh 22.
it's starting in March of 23 yeah
actually effectively April 1st of 23. so
that was one sort of unknown to all of
us I think throughout the sort of that
period there was every 90 days it had to
be reauthorized and there was no no
clear signal in terms of what what would
be expected so that was our best
sense of it when the budget was put
together for 22.23
we also with respect to the 24-25 budget
the fmap percentage right is in the
Consolidated appropriation Act is being
reduced from the 6.2 percent to the five
to the to the two and a half to the one
and a half
the criteria in which we had to to do
the unwind was also not known as what
we've been you know finalized as that
you can only do one-ninth of your
population
so that's another factor that goes into
it we we have a request in the current
budget because we're concerned about the
unwind and how fast we're actually able
to to to uh to unwind and what level of
appeals so far in the online you know
with one month's experience it's gone
according to plan but it's pretty early
in the process to to conclude how it's
going to play out because we the way we
approached our unwind was on a risk
basis those people we thought most
likely would close because they were
over income or were likely not were
likely ineligible or not used any
services in the past year that's who we
started with so the likelihood that
they're going to close and stay close as
high as we get into the the more
challenging populations the people that
you know have have coverage and have
shown use of Medical Services it's I
think the the variability and how that's
going to play out is is a little bit
more unknown and certainly something
that
um you know we would want to keep you
so it sounds like you're saying that
this increased fmap was more than we
needed to cover the expanded populations
under the emergency situation
but as that goes away
it's going to the remainder of the
funding that we in other words the
equivalent funding we have right now
this biennium is not going to be enough
to cover the lowered theoretically as we
phase people off to the extent of 70
million dollars
so the the online will run through
December okay and then there is medical
inflation that is occurring
um and then there was some anticipation
so we we figured we could operate within
about a three percent change in sort of
medical inflation and then whatever with
respect to um
some level of rate increase we
anticipated in terms of at the time
early on you know about a three percent
which turned out to be a a very low
assumption for 24.25 given what
um you know has come to be known of the
workforce shortage being even more
severe than what we started planning for
it but that's that's why you're seeing
an increase in in the 24-25 budget
certainly to the extent that our
contracts are not um their price
limitations if you will if we spend less
because we do better on enrollment and
and what have you that that money isn't
is isn't going to be spent except to
cover something like a known shortfall
you know we this particular shortfall is
a little bit um
hard to to work through and I understand
there's so many issues that come at the
the committee I'm working through but
this is a fixed dollar amount that we're
we're told that we have to pay for drug
coverage for people who are duly
eligible in the Medicaid Program it's a
it's a fixed premium per person per per
year per month and so when we bring
forth the number I understand it's been
hard to to take everything in but that
one is I think it's been several
bienniums where we haven't been able to
make a good case when we're presenting
it enough to to convince to to budget
directly for that as opposed to covering
it in a different fashion
one last question
firstly the last part he didn't
understand but I'll deal with that later
okay
um but more importantly for this note as
a whole and we've seen these several
times over the past well since I've been
doing this
um and I've asked as I were pretty sure
I've asked maybe you've forgotten that
I'd really like to see actual
spreadsheets provided to LBA when you
have notes like this
um so that I can actually understand
where the money's coming from and where
it's going to it was not easy for me I
understand they've got a lot of verbiage
in here and you got some pictures that
sort of show some of the going on that's
not really clear what's happening
um I'd really like to see that so like
so I can access something I can study to
understand where it's coming from where
it's going to because I'm always curious
as I was just asking about here how did
you happen to have so much money in this
account that we didn't that we were
unaware of particularly just as it went
through a budget cycle so that's just a
commentary that I really hope that
you'll please do that in the future
thank you we'd be happy to do that
Senator Rosenwald for a question
question about the state phase down if
we've known
since July and I'm not sure which July
maybe it was the beginning of the budget
that we had a shortfall
why did the department lapse
um along the way through
last fiscal year I think it was
something like
I know it was more than 30 million
dollars but it was maybe more than 50.
why didn't we
hang on to that additional Revenue
and supplant
General funds along the way to make up
the difference in this phase down
so we we have to pay the federal
government with General funds where
these payments are made CMS and we're
prohibited from supplanting generous
federal funds and general funds that's
that there's prohibition on that so
we're not allowed to do that which is
further questions on the item
I wanted to item
Senator gray moves that we adopted item
number one three four
Senator Bradley seconds is there any
further discussion
all in favor to say aye aye opposed no
no
one no
now we'll move on to tab 11.
we have a luminous report of vehicles
that didn't achieve
what I would like is an explanation of
why
I remember when this was twelve thousand
per year and
maybe an explanation of why
it has
come down year over year and buy the
also curious have we saved any money
from all these miles that haven't been
driven
so good morning uh Sherry Rockburn
assistant commissioner Department of
administrative services
so um there's a formula that we used and
it's we use it each biennium to
calculate the mileage what we call the
Benchmark mileage so as you remember as
you noted um chairman
ten thousand at one point it's down to
around eight thousand and that formula
is based on what we're actually spending
um in costs so we have direct cost and
operating costs that we use and we look
at the federal reimbursement rate to
calculate an average cost per mile
um the spreadsheet is the very last page
in your packets if you want to take a
look at it so some of this is just a
function of the formula it's not an
arbitrary mileage number that's
generated we actually calculate the
mileage based on sort of the average
number of vehicles we have the average
cost that's happening and the change in
the federal reimbursement rates
and so just as a comparison I'll just
give you a little background is while
this year this waivers for 119 vehicles
that fell below that mileage that
agencies had to ask for directly to
retain those Vehicles last year the
number was 165 vehicles
and the year before that was 111
so just to kind of give you a reference
of you know is 119 high is it low it's
uh you know somewhat um in between the
last two years over the three year
period this number hasn't fluctuated
significantly as you know the federal
mileage rate has um has traditionally
been increasing about every six months
or so so that's really the the nature of
this we don't determine I'll say exactly
if an agency should keep it or not we
ask the agencies for input for whether
they can they have a need for that
vehicle or not in terms of savings I
think the hard thing is while the
mileage driven has gone down as you know
the gas price that the pump has not so I
think that I wouldn't say we've had a
significant savings even though the
was that statement no significant
savings
no significant savings correct
is there any possibilities as you go
through these year after year from same
agencies that have low mileage vehicles
that they could do without one or two
especially where they have pool vehicles
and and there are always five vehicles
and there's two or three of them that
don't make it every year why do they
need them
we can continue to
um scrub that information when it comes
to us we do ask each commissioner to
submit information to our department
with a justification as sort of why they
need those Vehicles retained those
letters are attached to your fiscal
packet if you wanted to look at any
agency individually and they probably
could speak to it better than us we
really ask for their their input
directly I read a lot of them and they
all seem to sound the same about covid
working from home that sort of thing for
this last year but it seems like perhaps
going forward if they're not using these
vehicles as much they don't need as many
so I remember at a time when we went to
just four cylinder engines
small cars it doesn't seem like that
trend has continued
we've tried a few different things in
the fleet pool we've also tried to look
at leasing Vehicles instead of
state-owned and that had didn't produce
the savings that we had anticipated
um I think this past year we've also
struggled with as most individuals the
supply of vehicles so some of the
vehicles that we've traditionally have
requested at dealerships we've you know
have been a little bit limited as well
so that's been a little bit of a
struggle
what I didn't see in here is the total
number of vehicles you're tracking
I did have that um I believe that there
is
um and it's on a very small print on one
of the pages about just over 700
Vehicles 721 vehicles
thank you for the questions from the
committee
seeing none
are you ready to adopt the item
representative Leachman moves the item
Senator dalessandro seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye
pose no
moving on to tab 12
any I have any questions on the item I
have some questions Mr chairman
so representative leishman has a
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record I'm Joseph
malka chairman of the Liquor Commission
with me is our CEO James Vera and CFO
Tina Demir so we'd be happy to answer
any questions you might have thank you
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so I noticed in your
narrative this store was not one of your
profitable it was one of your least
profitable stores and it was interesting
to see that they'd have some flooding
issues here and so forth I guess the
concern I have is picking a store that's
at least profitable and especially in a
community that borders Massachusetts and
not too far from Vermont the impact it
has on the community of Winchester which
is a struggling town so I just curious
about your comments
well uh it was the least profitable
store the least profitable full-time
store when we closed it it had two
full-time employees and five part-time
employees and it's uh it's very close to
the Keene store in the Hinsdale store
which are both much larger Footprints
this store was about 4 000 square feet
at the time the the
ashlot River flooded the store we closed
the store James was in contact with the
landlord
who refused to play any damages
uh and then we use the store as a
storage facility for some shelving and
other things we move the product to the
larger stores in the area which are
millions of dollars higher in sales
so I think
to answer the question as to the effect
on the community I'm not really sure
that it had an effect on the community
as far as what we do as far as the the
business that we are in because we have
stores that are a couple of miles away
and serve those customers in Hinsdale on
the Vermont Border in Keene in range all
within that area and as you know
that area had a plethora of small stores
for a number of years quite frankly uh
underwhelming and underserving the
community and we are trying as we did in
West Chesterfield as we did in range as
we look forward to do in a couple other
communities out there to build larger
stores that are more impactful for the
consumers that come here from out of
state
thank you Mr chairman thank you thank
you representative
Senator dalessandro moves to accept the
item and
Senator Bradley seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye
oppose no
one know the item is adopted
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee have a wonderful weekend thank
you as well
chab 13 item number
23139 Department of Natural cultural
resources
any questions on this item
seeing none are you ready for the
question
Senator Bradley moosen in a seconds that
we adopt item 23139 for the discussion
seeing none you ready for the question
all in favor say aye
opposed no nothing
i-n-n-i-s Innis who are they in for
eign
foreign
transferring some items any questions on
representative leashman knows the item
Senator dalessandro seconds further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
aye
hey it looks like the one I have on top
is
the New Hampshire Youth Development
Center
23 140 and we have the honorable John
Broderick here for any questions excuse
me Mr chair there's two items you
mentioned the YDC item which is
informational only you do have one
action item which is the 23141 that you
may want to take a vote on prior very
all right so Fish and Game
is an action item
twenty three one four one that's a late
item
transferring 115 000.
to the operating budget any questions on
Senator dallasandra moves the item
Senator Bradley seconds that we adopt
item 23141 further discussion seeing
none all in favor say aye opposed no
Mr Kane any any uh action items that was
the last action item okay
any questions while we have
judge Broderick here on the
Senator Rosenwald has a question
thank you so much thank you for being
here
um
my question is about the expenses of
your office
I'm going to apologize up front I've had
a bad cold and my wife thinks I'm
ignoring her I'm not
telling I'm having trouble hearing okay
I'll try to speak loudly my question is
about the expenses of your office when I
total up
um your report in your expectation for
this year it's
um somewhere approaching a million
dollars for this year just wondering if
you project the same level expense for
the next two years or if you have a
sense of
what the expense of your office will be
that will be deducted from the fund
personal thank you it's it's a very good
question and it's perpetling to us
um
I've been in that office now for three
and a half months
we have received
claims as we've identified and this
committee knows probably better than I
the back story on all of this that
brought about this YDC claims office
uh
it's hard to know at this point how many
claims will find their way to our
doorstep
of the claims that have been filed to
date
with one exception none of them are
cases that are already in the Superior
Court
so part of the intention of the fund I
think was to have cases migrate from
this Prairie Court to the claims fund of
which there are about 800.
the claims we have received to date with
one exception have not been filed in
this prayer Court
so that group of cases which are
hundreds and hundreds are remaining in
place
and so it's hard to know whether they
will migrate in time
or none and if they migrate in time our
office will be busier than it is now and
expenses that we try to project
or expenses of an office that's
doing a very good job with a high level
of cases if we don't have the cases
expenses may be lost it's just just hard
Senator to know after three months I
the first trial in the superior court of
one of these sex abuse cases has
apparently been scheduled
for April of next year
12 months from now
the lawyers involved in that case
and the lawyers who have hundreds of
these cases I have no idea the severity
of them I don't know them
they may decide to stay put
they may decide to say let's see what
happens next April we'll have a jury
trial
and depending on what happens there we
may be doing a lot more business in the
claims office we may be doing Less
business
and in the backdrop of all of that
is the statute of limitations which this
legislature wisely created
so the statute of limitations for filing
Acclaim with us at the end of December
of 2024.
the first trial in the Supreme Court
unless it's resolved will be April of
2024.
depending on the result in that case
depending on whether it's appeal to our
Supreme Court I have no idea
the statute could run
my location is still alive
and so if lawyers are waiting
to see what happens in the court system
by the time they realize good better and
different the door may be closed here
so the claims process as you well know
doesn't go on forever
what I would be interested in doing and
and I think you know you created the job
and I give you Kudos I mean that for
creating this
it was exactly the right thing to do
there's a fair amount of misinformation
out there there's a fair amount of
ignorance out there about what this is
really about and how it's really going
to work
this legislature decided and I think
wisely to create this fund
to do it in a way that was trauma
informed
critically important and everyone saw
that
the court system as you know as good as
it is is not trauma-informed it's often
trauma-inducing
so in terms of
what we're trying to accomplish here
what you put in place I think is exactly
right
if the legislature is interested in
hearing from a neutral I am totally
neutral here
I do not have a horse in this race I'm
proud to be the administrator I want to
do the right thing
and I'm pretty circumscribed by the
statute with the Caps not complaining
that's that's what it is
but over the last three or four or five
months I've had a number of discussions
with counsel
I've had one meeting with all Council
about eight or ten of them I have most
of these cases I have another meeting
scheduled with them
at the end of this month
I've been reaching out to the Department
of Corrections I mean I've really been
trying to touch base with the
stakeholders I want to learn as much as
I can
but at the end of the day my answers are
exactly the same as yours and the same
as the people
who were sexually assaulted or
physically assaulted
and I want to resolve these cases in a
trauma-informed
confidential if the claimants choose to
keep it as such and most will I believe
process that's reasonably prompt
trauma informed
but if you're interested at some point I
know you have a long day today
after three or four months of dealing
with it and having those conversations I
do have some thoughts about what you
might consider doing
to bring more people into the system
some of them I think would cost nothing
some of them might cause something in
some of those cases
but
as someone who's running that office now
and knowing the intention of this
legislature
I think it would be profoundly said
20 months from now they have the Fun
close
and not many people who came into the
system
at that point the only place to go is
the court system with all its attendance
stress
and all its attendant press
and at the end of the day that won't
accomplish what you want in my view
it certainly won't accomplish a
trauma-informed resolution
and so if there's interest at some time
I'd love to sit down with all of you
some of you
just to share some thoughts obviously
you're free to reject every one of them
I understand that
my goal is to make this work
because the system you've created I
think is inherently fair I I don't have
any doubt about it I wouldn't be
associated with it if I thought
otherwise I know a lot of people here
did a lot of hard work to get to this
point the attorney general has been very
Cooperative with our office
I'm independent I'm neutral but I deal
with the Attorney General's office I
deal openly with climate Council
I want this system to work
and I think it may require some
adjustments to meet the goals you want
and if there's ever any interest I'd be
for the questions from committee members
seeing none we look forward to further
reports thank you judge
Mr chairman did you say we're all done
yes thank you very much thank you uh
it's been a while Mr chairman since I've
been here I apologize
but my wife will vouch for it I can't
hear that well right now thank you very
much thank you
there are further informational items as
seeing none we're ready to move on to
the
foreign
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record Steve Smith director of
audits for the LBA
we're here to present the the annual uh
single audit of federal expenditures
as you know our office retains KPMG to
perform in this audit so with us from
KPMG the partner on the engagement is
Marie Zimmerman
and also dean of call our State
Comptroller for any questions and
comments she may have so thank you we'll
have KPMG present their audit all right
good morning chairman senators and
members of the committee my name is
Marie Zimmerman thank you for the
introduction Steve I'm presenting to you
today the results of the state of New
Hampshire's Federal single audit for the
year ended June 30th 2022. this is as
you know a compliance audit
the total federal expenditures reported
on the schedule of federal expenditures
and awards was 3.5 billion dollars and
was approximately a billion dollars less
than the year before
that is primarily related to the
decrease of co-fed funding of which 900
million was directly related to the
unemployment program
section e of is where the CFA is located
in your boundary port with the green
cover
and on page one
um you will see the schedule of federal
expenditures and awards which is listed
by federal agency as well as aln number
the total expenditures also include
included within the total expenditures
as required to be reported is the amount
of the password to sub-recipients and
this year there was a total pass-through
of 783 million dollars
the sifa is prepared by the state as a
part of the audit we review the sifa and
perform a variety of procedures to
determine the completeness and accuracy
of the sifa that it was properly
prepared as a part of our opinion which
begins on page D3 we concluded that the
sifa is fairly stated in all material
respects in relation to the basic
financial statements as a whole we
previously presented on the basic
financial statements and provided a
clean opinion on those
as outlined by the uniform guidance
requirements we are not required to
audit every program on the CFA instead
we are required to focus our audit on
certain large dollar programs as
identified as type A programs and higher
risk type B programs per the uniform
guidance
for the year ended June 30th 2022 the
type a major program threshold was 10.6
million dollars as shown in our summary
of audit reports on page F1
the amount is noted that the summary of
the Arvada reports begins on page F1 but
the announcement is noted on page F3
that threshold determines our type A
programs there was 25 Federal programs
for the state that had received funding
or expenditures incurred of greater than
10.6 million
the largest be in your Medicaid Program
at 1.8 billion dollars
the uniform guidance requires Auditors
to perform risk assessments over each
program that meets or exceeds that type
a threshold
to determine which programs will be
audited once the type a threshold risk
assessment is determined the risk
assessments are performed over the type
B to identify which programs are will be
determined high risk and subject to our
audit
this year was unique the federal
government as you know deemed 10
programs to be higher risk historically
only Medicaid was deemed higher risk so
taking this into account and Performing
our required risk assessment process we
identified a total of 19 major programs
as you may recall that is greater than
the previous two years as audited
programs
of those 19 programs 16 rear type A
and three uh three were type B programs
the type B programs all three of them
were deemed higher risk programs by the
federal government
those were airport Improvement program
Federal Transit and then provider relief
in addition of the 18 audit programs 10
of those had been audited in the
previous year the June 30th 2021 audit
and were required to be re-audited as a
result of the findings in the prior year
audit those include Medicaid Title 1
unemployment insurance Corona really fun
emergency rental assistance program
education stabilization snap TANF ELC
and LIHEAP
as a result of our audit procedures
performed we identified 32 reportable
findings related to the uniform guidance
audit for this year
of the 32 reportable findings are in our
opinion is outlined in section D of the
report
24 of those findings are considered
material weaknesses and internal
controls
eight of them were considered to be
significant deficiencies in internal
controls
we're considered to be material
non-compliance
of which six of those related to the
reporting compliance audit area five
related to sub-recipient monitoring and
five related to special tests
the good news for of these 24 findings
none related to allowability or
eligibility
I do want to point out that 10 of the 24
material non-compliance findings are
within three programs
I know one of them you've already noted
today which is LIHEAP also TANF and then
the small business credit initiative
technical assistant grant program
of the 32 findings reported 13 of them
of the 32 programs three this year had
question cost
special education finding cluster had a
question cost over a period of
performance in the amount of 124
thousand dollars TANF had a special
reporting compliance finding resulted in
question costs of just 222.
which did not rise to a material
non-compliance and then TANF had a
question cost in the amount of Thirteen
thousand five hundred thirty I just
wanted to draw the question cost to your
attention
based on the results of our audit
procedures performed we are required to
provide an opinion related to the
compliance of each Mega program audited
based upon the internal controls and
compliance identified as shown within
our summary of audit results we issued a
qualified opinion
over 13 of the 19 programs we audited
those were the ones that were considered
the material weaknesses and in material
weakness and internal control as well as
the material non-compliance
an unmodified or clean opinion was
issued over six of your programs and the
good news here the story to tell is
those were some of your largest new
covid funding programs such as your
provider relief and American Rescue plan
your pandemic EBT your airport
Improvement your CRF fund as well as
well as your Federal Transit formula
grant
of the 13 programs that received the
modified opinions
um I mean the unqualified opinions
unmodified opinions seven of those
also received unmodified opinions in
their qualified opinions in the previous
year
those would have included so those fine
they were qualified last year they're
qualified this year the seven programs
include snap emergency rental program
education stabilization ELC TANF LIHEAP
of the 13 programs that received
modified funding 10 of them had covet
funding as well
the findings themselves begin on page F4
of the report the first finding relates
to our financial statement audit we had
I had previously presented the results
of those findings as it related to
unemployment compensation trust fund in
our presentation earlier in this year
for each of the findings included in the
report management is required to provide
a response to the findings which is also
included at the bottom of each of the
findings as well as their corrective
action plan to resolve the matter
the corrective action plans are
presented to contain within the report
as outlined in our opinion the state is
responsible for preparing the corrective
action plans and the state's responses
were not subject to our audit
and as such we do not express an opinion
as it relates to those corrective action
plans
does anyone have any questions I know I
covered a lot but I know that you had
detailed knowledge of the report
this is a Monumental effort how many
Auditors were involved
my team we consist of approximately 40
professionals between it and CPE CPA
audit professionals as well as LBA staff
to assist us I knew it was almost more
questions from the committee
I guess when they dump all this money on
us at once it's difficult to figure out
where it all has to be reported and how
it's reported some of these things that
I read were very difficult to follow all
of a sudden you're a you're a
pass-through whereas before you were a
distributor distributor and now you have
all these other things that come up that
you know and and you failed up and and
looking for disbarment on someone that
you're
passing things to what if they're not a
lawyer can they still be disbarred
I mean I read these in several places
and wondered
this is a person that doesn't do any law
work why would they be dispared so
is that a term used in other areas as
well as law yes it is so the federal
government has deemed that entity
um that not-for-profit as having not
reputable and should not be receiving
federal funds
so that's what I I assume just Barman
was a wider net than what I originally
assumed yeah so appreciate all this
information obviously it's been
difficult every year there's summary
page is appreciated that tells us what's
going on in previous years so it's it's
not an easy task when they especially
the amount of money that gets dumped and
I don't think we get much warning and
then there's a whole new set of rules so
I think
the groups have done pretty well
considering all these problems that have
suddenly you get a bunch of new money
and it's got to be dispersed right away
and you've got to report right away and
we're short of people so and you have to
set up the policies and procedures in
accordance with compliance and so that's
really a story to tell that management
those were clean opinions over those
programs that management really put in
the level of effort necessary because if
you look at your bulk of your findings
or over the long-term existing programs
the Mr chair if I if I may uh Dana call
State Comptroller I do just want to
recognize
um all of the finance staff that in
addition to the programmatic
responsibilities uh the finance staff at
these agencies many of which did not get
additional resources that came with
these funds
um as you look through the actual FIFA
spend expenditures you can see that
covid-19 money that is highlighted in
each category some of which has been
infused in additional already existing
programs but they got an influx of
additional funding perhaps with no
additional resources to manage those
funds so I do want to recognize the
agency staff as well as my staff led by
Steve juvenile who has been preparing
this Monumental book for several years
and after his stint with gopher came
back to us and was able to pick right up
and and we're really pleased that the
findings have maintained at a reasonable
level that we think we can manage going
forward so
thank you very great
um my concern is the repeating items uh
not only on this side audit but other
Audits and and I haven't been able to
pin anybody down uh whether it's
administrative services or somewhere
else uh that needs to be the one that
tracks these things and looks at them
current status Etc you know plan of
action Milestones uh those kind of
things because we shouldn't have all the
repeating items that we've had in the
last few months so thank you
yeah thank you for the comment excuse me
and we do
um we have administrative Services have
a corrective Action Report filing status
program that we work with each
commissioner to engage them in in really
following up quarterly on these findings
we did have some slippage in that
because of the movement with our staff
over to gopher and and now we're going
to pick that back up so I do think it
falls on both equally it falls on
administrative services to Monitor and
for the agencies to actually Implement
their corrective action plans but we do
have a tool to to monitor that
follow-up just uh after the budget's
done come see me excellent I will thank
you and if you have a follow-up report
we'd be interested especially on these
items that recur
and I forgot to welcome Senator Innis as
and also on our side we have
representative Mooney sitting in for
representative Edwards so and as as
usual I have my my faithful alternate
members
here always to make sure they stay up
with everything and I appreciate them
representative he's sitting in for
I'll recognize representative erf for
emotion move to accept place on oops no
go ahead I was just going to ask to do
that
better than say mood to adjourn accept
the report move to accept placed on file
and released to the public in the usual
manner
is there a second second second from
Senator gray further discussion seeing
none all in favor say aye
aye opposed no thank you for all that
busy work
that's a long term
just one more item Mr chairman just the
date of the next meeting
we will have a session on the 18th so
uh we will have finished up a lot of the
stuff in the in the house how about the
Senate any more convenient time
the Fallen law enforcement offers
service memorial service he said on the
19th is the 19th at 10 A.M
same time we'd be starting
yeah
that's happened to double types what
happened has it hasn't interfered
unless it might be hard to find your way
into the parking garage but can I ask
that would have done it yeah and the
idea is try to move things is
problematic because of other things so
that's right as you have other things
going on
I have a question for the committee it
seems somewhere along the line we
switched from being the second
Friday to being the third Friday and the
third Friday has traditionally been our
executive committee meeting in the
county which I've not been able to go to
for
a while now
and I'm just wondering if you've got a
problem does
well something definitely changed
because on the on the second it may be
all right maybe you're correct but on
the second Friday I have the judicial
retirement medium that hasn't changed in
fact I had them move it until later in
the afternoon so that I could go to do
this in the morning I
if it's possible change would be great
if not I'll just deal with it I'll just
tell them if would you be done with your
meeting in in the by noon time yes
so on the second on the second Friday
though I believe on the 19th there's
already meeting scheduled for yeah in
the afternoon Health and Human Services
oversight committee is in the afternoon
this is why I brought up the second
Friday I was hoping the second Friday
would have worked better for people
would that be the 12th what do you what
do you have on the second Friday the
12th
questions
nothing
in the third too that that's the fourth
I'm sorry I said the fourth
nice
to be the fourth okay the fourth
the executive committee's being the
fourth
it's today
so the Hillsborough County is not on the
19th okay I guess not
no it is on the 19th apparently no no
26th I don't believe you because I've
missed it like three times because of
this
all right so that's not a that's not a
all right let's make it 10 a.m on
on May 19th
or fiscal
um
any any idea Mr Kane will there be a lot
of items or are there any uh Mr Smith
will be bringing in several audits or
one at the most okay
you'll start to pick up on the number of
items due to the end of the year so um
you're probably still anybody's guess
it's a little heavier than this I would
guess in the 40 item range for the next
couple months
so but we were successful on covering
most of them on a on a consent calendar
so
all right
May 19th 10 o'clock next meeting
anything further
committee is adjourned
thank you all for coming
all right so
when I have my when I have all my stuff
together I'll get together with you